let's take back where do we what was the
first thing we began with under indices
powers exponent what's the definition of
an index if I wrote you know a to the
power M what does that even mean it
means a times a times a how many times M
times right okay so let's actually write
that it's a times a times a I don't know
however many times M is right but it
goes one or five or 60 whatever it is
right so I'm right that that is M times
that's what a to the M a the power of M
rather is okay so then we took this idea
and we said look we can we can build on
this right if you have two numbers like
this ATM and a to some other base right
so this is what we were and if you
remote apply them by each other right
you could rewrite it like this and count
it up but that's what forever instead we
wrote down what we call an index law
right it's equal to that base and what's
the power what do you do when you when
you multiply you add the the indices
right so it's M plus in case it's
ringing bells yes okay in exactly the
same way if I go division like this okay
you subtract the indices okay you take
the difference so far so good
and then one of the most important
things we dealt was you know if these
two numbers are the same m and n right
etienne - divided by ad n you get a to
the power of 0 right but then we said
well that must be 1 there must be one
that was the last more if you like that
we established so there's 1 2 3 laws
then we raise this question okay we said
for any number the power of 0 its 1 in
the same way you know I can put this on
the side 0 to the power of any number
that's 0
right 0 squared 0 cube 0 ^ 100 0 ^ maybe
paying attention
waiting money for you away cool thank
you
so yeah ah good yes so what happens when
you put these together right a number to
the power 0 is 1
any 0 0 the power any number is 0 so
what happens when you put them together
ok yeah yeah therein lies the question
now here's where we're going to do it
and you'll need your calculators for
this ok in fact I'm going to get mine
out we're going to need everyone's
calculators as well so I'm going to ask
you to help me do some numbers okay so
get your calculator up ok so here's the
thing right if you're looking from this
angle if you're approaching along this
way from this guy your tag could be 0 if
you come from this direction you'd
expect 1 so is it either of those or is
it something different entirely ok
here's what we're gonna do um I'm gonna
draw up a table you don't need to draw
this table but you're gonna help me fill
it in ok mmm
what I want us to think about is what
these numbers are equal to if I'm
starting to get close to you know really
small numbers ^ really small numbers ok
so if you want what we're about to do is
something called limits I'll explain
that shortly but just so you know we're
doing right and here's what you need on
your calculator in the middle up the top
there's a power button ok it looks like
an X with a little square sort of filled
in at the corner okay so if you type
that in for example if you go let me
turn this on if you seven then you press
that power button right and that little
box will appear so this is what I typed
up at 7 then I'll type that X with a box
now if we type something like 3
so now three appears up in the power
right so seventh the base and three is
the pound you press equals and you get
there 43 okay so seven cubed is 343
here's what we gonna do I want us all to
get a whole bunch of different numbers
okay
so hands up who's got a proper
calculator like not another phone at
proper one good okay so here's what I'm
gonna do I'll go right down a series of
things right and then I want us to work
out what their value is okay so value
and and mmm
I'm sure like all this I'll leave that
plane I'll think of a bad name in a
second okay so really important we do
the arm the calculations with your
calculator so raise your hand again so I
can assign some numbers okay everyone
rezian so I can see okay all right Jagr
you get my hardest one okay you get one
of the power of one okay keep your hand
up Kyle
you get 0.92 the power of 0.9 just fine
yeah
okay Jack you can do 0.8 to the power of
0.8 you see I'm going right Tom point
seven was your right good okay
all right let's start from the top and
again remember three decimal places okay
jad make sure you read it carefully
don't miss out any details what did you
get I won one but any decimal places
okay so I'm going to go to zero zero
zero is that okay there you go
all right Kyle you a next point nine
zero nine zero nine zero point nine zero
nine okay good um were you next shot
zero point eight three six okay good Tom
seven seven nine okay I want to pause
for a second before we get to Lucas's
number just look up for a second and
let's have a look at what's happening
just have a look at what's happening
okay I'm trying to establish a pattern
can you see the numbers again explorance
but i'm trying to get to this right try
it closer and close up at this point if
you had to guess at this point what
would you think would happen when we get
to zero power zero what does it look
like it's going to it looks like they
going to zero right
they were dropping oh right well let's
keep going
I can't who we up to Lucas 736 okay who
is next was it
Nelson yeah zero point zero seven zero
seven zero seven okay alright house - I
know okay good now we'll pause there for
a meter on the next number the people
who are suspicious before should now
have cause to be even more suspicious
because look the numbers are decreasing
right ah but not much look at these guys
right they're getting quite close
together they are decreasing but they're
slowing down yeah that's right well
actually we call that's exactly what it
is we call this exponential growth but
what we're looking at seems to be
exponential decay but anyway that's an
assign gets even more interesting okay
who had point three yeah 6000 and six
what what happened why am i slowing down
is not even slowing down it's gone the
other way turn around okay let's keep
going point to hold on to for we're
climbing again we're climbing okay Chloe
go ahead okay now this is interesting
I'm getting closer I know I'm getting
there but I'm number one I'm not there
number two you see how from here to here
we were slowing down right these these
gaps are getting very very small but now
that I turned around the gaps are
getting bigger see that's that graphs
like point three this gaps like point
seven right so what's going on okay now
we need more numbers so we need your
calculators again here the numbers I'm
going to suggest let's go let's get half
of this what's half of point one I think
it's point oh five isn't it so Jarrod
you got gypped out by doing one to the
power of one so why don't you do point
oh five to the power of point oh five
okay um Kyle do you want to do let's go
smaller again that's great point O to
some power point Oh - okay Jack joined
0.01 okay I'll tell you what the next
one is in a second Jack can tell me what
yours is zero point eight six zero hmm
still in cooking increasing yeah 0.9 0.9
- four still increasing yeah zero point
nine five four hmm okay now this time we
sort of been going towards zero but in
smaller chunks okay I want to get there
faster okay so this time Tom what I want
you to put in is and other people can
see if they get the answer faster
feeling let's go ten times smaller at
zero point zero zero one okay what do
you get yes
993 okay let's go again let's go ten
times smaller again zero zero zero 1 ^
0.0001 once that equals sir you got it
Lukesh yeah yeah ah
now just because we've hit mines what
are the odds out of curiosity what are
the other decimal places okay all right
Ali Ali can you do the next one
let's do 0.00001 that's four zeros and
to the power of zero point zero zero
zero is your one as four zeros one yeah
four zeros and then one what do we get
and I'm going to need more decimal
places this time what happened to the
break ah you missed a 1 there oh go go
back to the beginning
okay Matt era what'd you get zero point
yeah I'm 908 407 okay cool alright I'll
go there yeah okay
five zero is five whoops sorry
- one two three four five yep okay okay
signing at the point nice now this is
interesting I I'm correct if you can go
far enough with your calculator I think
you will convince your calculator then
it gets to one I suspect
okay I can't well you can sit down you
can try and prove it but can you see
we've done two things okay first we saw
it dropping down right but then it
turned around it started to increase
like this but then it didn't increase
forever oh really
okay did anyone get a one how many zeros
I have to put on I use you can spam you
just kept on going to your rows until
okay five minutes ago 20 20 zeros I can
t go so what you've done by the way to
get one all you've done is you your
calculator has run out of nines that's
all its own like if we had a longer
calculator or maybe some of your phones
have more digits on those that don't you
go
it doesn't have it doesn't have notation
so that one and also the 9s don't repeat
forever
there are other numbers here so you
can't use a repeater okay so therefore
therefore we never got to 0 it's not 1 0
but the well it's not quite either is it
but the the best definition that you get
like what it seems to be going toward is
it seems to be going toward 1 okay
that's the best we can say but I don't
bother yes well see it starts to break
down if you go further cuz with
negatives it doesn't quite work well see
here's the thing this ants are like this
is an answer we decide the numbers and
the you know we start from our
definition right so it's what makes the
most sense in this context okay let me
finish it off by coming back to this
idea what you are all doing with your
calculators who is called taking a limit
there's this idea this thing which is
approaching a certain number we can
never get there but you can get very
close so if you're the curious type you
can write this and you can wow your
friends with it okay it's a bit of weird
notation but I'll explain what it means
in a second you should write it down
then it looks like this okay this thing
what does it mean that that either it
means see this thing right it means as X
approaches 0 right you can see the error
X is going there okay as X gets closer
and closer and closer to 0 what happens
to this guy here this that ^ itself
and the answer is it goes to that that's
what it does okay it never gets there
but that's where it's going if it could
get there that's what happened okay so I
hope that gives you a conclusive answer
um that's why if you go and look up on
the internet which I know some of you
did that's why you'll find this is the
conclusion yeah you mean why does it
turn around here now that's a good
question and I don't have an answer to
that at least I mean I don't have one
right now probably because I um really
thought about it all that much to be
honest um I wonder I mean there's always
there's always reasons for everything so
maybe we could find out where they go